that's not the plan
hey that was that so I mean Houston had
their their their their moment they had
their Swisher house it was the right
time to do in Houston well we did the
Pimp C tribute too so we had all these
artists come out and do Pimp C covers
um at that show you know I I gotta ask
you because obviously you were so close
with Pimp C you obviously wrote his book
um if you like you said 700 Pages if you
ever want to know anything about Pimp C
it's in there well like like
how many phones did he have because I
had always heard this dude was like very
into cell phones like he had like a lot
of phones or it was like something like
he just like you know I
remember him having more than one
remember that he
I mean right like I did a photo shoot
with him when he had first got out of
prison I think he really wanted the I
think his mom talked about this
um I remember his mom talking about how
he really wanted a razor like that was
the thing when he was locked up he
wanted a Motorola Razor was it Motorola
yeah yeah yeah yeah so when he got out
they had the Motorola for him and so he
wanted to do
um a photo shoot with it actually well
what happened was I I had been
corresponding with him I interviewed him
while he was in prison and so I hear
that he's getting out and I'm like
should I go you know what I mean and I
didn't really have a it's I think it's
like a week out so I'm like I don't
really have any way to reach him and be
like do you want me to be there because
you know some artists coming out of
prison I'm like do they want the media
there family and so I think I had called
bun and Bun was like very like
non-committal like didn't really give me
an answer one way or the other so I'm
like
I mean I'm always one I'm just gonna go
for it you know and I said well I'll go
and I'll just hang back if he doesn't
want to take pictures I just wasted a
trip it is what it is but um he did let
me take pictures and but then he kind of
called me a few days later and was kind
of like that's not how I want to be
presented you know he just come out of
prison he wants he wants the car and the
jewelry and the photo so he's like come
back to Houston we'll do a photo shoot
so he got the Bentley at that point he
got all the jewelry he's got the Razor
and so he's posing with the phone like
every shot he's got you know the phone
out hanging out the car with the phone
in his hand like
so that's a great um and this is this is
a good story too
this was uh or I don't know it's kind of
a bad story I did this whole photo shoot
with him at a video shoot in Miami
um it was R Kelly was it R Kelly T-Pain
R Kelly video shoot and we did this
whole shoot with him with the mink and
it was supposed to go to Vibe magazine
and I had sent Vibe like
one picture like a little small low
here's what we got today drive to
Atlanta go to the ti release party leave
all my luggage in the car like a rookie
come back out of the club and
everything's gone the whole photo shoot
is just disappeared so all I have is the
one little picture that I emailed to
Vibe so that's how I had artists that's
crazy
how sweaty was he in Miami wearing that
because I'd heard that's a great
question I heard a quote that he said
that uh that that uh TV don't got
temperature yeah I think that's where my
book
or maybe it came somewhere else first
but um I'm sure he had he had to have
been pretty hot I don't know yeah it's
crazy because you've obviously I mean
you know for you like you know being
able to kind of tell like the Pimp C
story in a way that is very
comprehensive very thorough
um do you kind of look at yourself as
like somebody who is like a historian of
of hip-hop at this point because you
were there for so much of an era that I
I think like
now we look back I don't you know I
always tell people like
uh especially in sports I'm like you
don't realize like what we're watching
or what we're a part of or what we're
seeing on TV like you don't know about
like you're not gonna appreciate LeBron
until 10 years from now when he's gone
you know and I feel like that era of
Southern hip-hop and everybody who came
out of that was still relevant who are
still I mean you mentioned Rick Ross and
cheesy and all these people who are just
still Staples of our culture like but
you were like in the just front row of
the Reddit like really the beginning of
all of this stuff
so do you kind of like I'm glad I was
there yeah I do consider myself a
historian I mean not honestly not just
for hip-hop but just I'm I'm into
history period right
um I really look at not only our time
period but just you know I have all
kinds of weird theories about like even
just how we live like our lifestyles
like people did not always live this way
like we live I mean you know I've been
on some other like I'm off adventuring
like hiking and it just makes you think
about different
um you know people didn't always live
like this we don't really need like
these big houses and cars and stuff like
there's